we've got about a hundred sector cows
and we've got a thousand users and it's
the job I love oh I've done it ever
since I left school so that's about
their cash is about 30 years now I think
when you think of the tapestry the
backdrop the patchwork of feels that
Wales is it's just really special in my
belief in Brecon brexit is getting real
how relevant is the idea of even
pondering that the price of these land
could for 30% okay so at the present
time I look at what politicians say I
watch the news day in day out and I look
to where we are in terms of red lines
and what they say in okay and when I
hear that we're leaving the customs
union will leave in the single market I
then draw an equation then what market
access that gives me and at the present
time
that's not very high up the steps to
free and frictionless trade it's really
really serious no this is game time no
because this is people's businesses this
is people's futures and I would say it's
the future of wings you know we've got
six nine point nine billion contribution
to the Welsh economy this is all in
danger if we have a bad deal we'll have
use lam you know in a couple of weeks
time those lands will be sold in a post
brexit market some of them I need to
know that I've got a market place for
them I need to know that I'm not going
to be swamped by imports and how I break
on my export capability on this farm
alone they've cut back the number of use
by 100 the industry facing a double
whammy barriers to the market that takes
almost all their exports and at the same
time a new wave of competition from free
trade deals with the agricultural
powerhouses of the southern hemisphere
well there are some opportunities from
an independent trade policy after brexit
for the welsh hill farmers the priority
is definitely maintaining access to
European markets on existing terms
there is the lingering suspicion that in
the desperate - to sign quick trade
deals with New Zealand on Australia the
interest of communities like this could
be traded away
certainly very high up the list of
immediate priorities for trade deals
after brexit a New Zealand and Australia
and yet those same Commonwealth allies
have thrown a great spanner in the work
of trade secretary Liam Fox to establish
the UK's position at the World Trade
Organization the UK currently trades
with such countries on the basis of
negotiated EU wide imports tariff rates
quotas for example for 225,000 tonnes a
year have imported New Zealand sheep
meat Liam Fox agreed with the EU that
the UK's historic share of imports of
around 80 thousand tons would be carved
out of the EU quota but powerful
agricultural nations including New
Zealand Australia and Donald Trump's USA
have objected saying their trade access
has been reduced they want to maintain
the same quota they currently enjoy to
both the EU and UK markets effectively
threatening to throw open a whole new
negotiation and the need for immediate
concessions on access to UK markets
Australia's High Commissioner the ex
foreign minister Alexander Downer says
it's all about free trade you give us
some you the European Union give us
these tiny quotas on the beef and lamb
beef yes beef lamb and so on
so as sugar you give us these tiny
quotas now when you leave the EU you the
UK and the Europeans have decided that
what you'll do is you'll slice off some
of the EU quota we have to take into
consideration the amount of that quota
we've been exporting to the UK we want a
situation when you leave the EU whereby
we're not initially any worse off than
we currently are but people like well
sheep farmers and cattle farmers they
want to stay protected and they're
worried about Australia New Zealand
cattle and Lao coming in and they think
that this is a ruse to put them out of
business though well it won't have known
tension of putting out of business
famously a majority in Wales voted to
leave the European Union but Teresa Mays
general election brexit message also
fell flat
a year later Welsh First Minister Carwyn
Jones judges
it isn't just farmers but workers in the
steel industry and engine factories -
that believe protecting livelihoods here
means continuing participation in the
single markets and customs union after
brexit we don't want to see a stitch-up
behind closed doors that destroys Welsh
farming and the UK government have to
give assurances in in that regard but
whilst farming relies on exports I'd
relies heavily on exports of the
European Union not just that year we
exported the Middle East is as well but
without our biggest single market with
barriers being put in our way to export
to our biggest single market how can I
possibly be good for while farming it's
never gonna be good and we have to make
sure we come to an agreement with the EU
first it's on our doorstep few
livelihoods are as potentially impacted
by brexit as Hill farming currently
majority funded by EU subsidies and with
almost all exports going to the EU and
the prospects of new markets limited by
ferocious competition the equation is
different for other industries even
other types of farm but from Brecon and
beyond the message is that the much
promised post brexit free-trade near
Varna will be far from straightforward
faisal Islam Sky News in the Brecon
Beacons